now what what was the catalyst what was
the
straw that broke the camel's back
for you
and as far as your reporting and you not
being welcomed back into russia
you mean why why was it that i was
expelled in 2013.
yeah obviously you had been
your reporting was not favored
right by the russian authorities for
your entire stay in russia for the
entire time you were reporting from
moscow right i mean yeah you know i
assume that
your work was not pro-russian with not
like a pro-russian view
well was it was i i i felt that it was
neither pro-russian or anti-russian that
it was an attempt just to show things as
they
as they were
uh
what was there was there
one specific story
well i think that my writing about the
apartment bombings pushed their the
limits of their tolerance but i also was
in a kind of situation you have to
understand that the soviet union
and russia
are
a very unusual countries in that
they are uh dictatorships and they are
repressive but they try
to give the impression
that they are democratic
and in order to create that illusion
which they then are very adept at
manipulating to their own advantage
they're ready to tolerate
a certain amount of freedom
and i pushed that freedom to the outer
limit for
they didn't want to expel me earlier
because that would have been
acknowledging the truth of what i was
writing they wanted to take the view
that and and they wanted to convince
others
that you know i was just spouting some
kind of conspiracy theory and of course
that didn't bother them you know was
just irresponsible
and uh
but the situation changed in 2013
because the whole situation in russia
changed
as a result of the uh euro maidan right
the myon massacre no well the maidan
first of all the protests right the the
massacre the sniper massacre came later
okay that was it yeah the sniper mascara
was towards the end right it was in
february of 2014 but the euro maidan was
uh the scene of massive popular
demonstrations
against
victor yanukovych who was then the
president
of ukraine and who was you know
comparatively pro-russian
in any case that rattled
the the russian authorities
because that income
first of all in 2011 there had been
protests in russia over falsified
parliamentary elections those those
those protests fizzled out
but
a the protest movement in the former
soviet union
you know
reappeared in effect in ukraine
and
it was ultimately successful
but the mere thought of 300 000 people
on the street demanding
an end to the government of a
kleptocratic ruler
that was enough to unsettle the russian
authorities and to
and to to make them reevaluate that
that area of tolerance that they had
that that they had previously
extended to liberals foreigners
and it turns out i was in russia there's
an expression perfect elastica
means the first swallow
at the first sign of something i was in
my expulsion was in in effect
the the first swallow of the wave of
repression that would uh
engulf russia because i although i was
ma they the one of the first things they
did was to expel me maybe the first
thing then there were other repressive
measures and a lot of other things
happen i mean in the end boris nemtsov
for example was murdered
a lot of other people were expelled that
were uh
uh
not journalists but but
there was a a tightening
of repression across the board but i the
first sign of this was my expulsion and
i think it was connected with the idea
that you know under conditions in which
people have shown their ability to take
to the streets even if they did it in a
neighboring country
russia could not afford the level of
tolerance and liberalism that it had
been demonstrating
don't you think it was crazy how
uh
the american american politicians such
as john mccain would go there and and be
a part of rallies
pro
pro pro like with the opposition and
like rallying them and showing support
with them and seems to just be deepening
the divide and the chaos there
are we talking about ukraine oh yeah i'm
talking about maidan
um
when you were talking about the people
on the streets in maidan uh during that
thing before the massacre
that these
u.s diplomats were showing up on the
streets and rallying with these people
and
not they were
deepening the chaos they were
pouring gas on this thing and they
weren't trying to i mean could you
imagine that happening in the u.s could
you imagine
a protest like this happening in
washington and diplomats from other
countries coming here and
handing out water bottles or or
supporting these protests like you would
never see something like that happen it
just seems so crazy well actually during
the soviet period they there there were
uh such such things
um
but but
but i don't think that the appearance of
i mean if we talk about maidan for now
for the moment
i don't think that the appearance of
john mccain or any other american
official
was particularly important uh to what
happened in ukraine
except you know that that some politics
foreign politicians are showing up and
saying we support you
but and
those politicians are not well informed
uh they don't say anything you know very
intelligent
when they get up on the stage
there were uh
in the maidan all kinds of people were
showing up
russian dissidents uh various artistic
people people from all over the world
coming in to express their support for
the protest
but
uh the
they their role i mean was not uh
was not decisive
um
what determined the the the course of
events
uh
were
forces within ukrainian society itself
uh why are you talking about like the
the nazi militias the the far-right
groups that were inciting the violence
the the well
you had you had you have to understand
what you had here
you had uh a leader
uh
viktor yanukovych
who was massive massively corrupted and
had
established a very corrupt system
you had a country
with lots of problems
which was nonetheless
hoping uh and many people were hoping to
move toward the west and which
did not want russian and russian
domination they wanted independence
there were pro-russian elements in the
country no question about it and
particularly in the east ukraine but
overall
the sentiment was for an independent
country we know this
because in
1991 when the soviet union broke up uh
ukraine the ukrainian population voted
by over 90 percent for independence and
that included even the russian-speaking
areas like crimea and
east ukraine
you